right back for top story tonight the
House Intelligence Committee voting to
release the classified memo thanks to a
lot of you tweeting out calling your
Congressman yours and saying release the
memo
now following the vote Democrats and
members of the mainstream media
immediately began condemning the move
they don't want to see the memo and they
especially don't want you to see the
memo take a look all you need to
understand is that the Republicans
declared war today on our national
security on classified information I
think we're seeing a breakdown to
democracy here we've never had a
situation in which the Congress has
moved into a criminal investigation and
begun and turned it into a political
circus and that's exactly what's going
on here it looks a lot like Watergate
it also has fringes of the Salem witch
trials and you throw in the McCarthy
hearings and I think we've got one
crisis about to happen here all right
joining us now former White House press
secretary for President Trump Sean
Spicer and former White House press
secretary for President George W Bush
Fox News contributor Ari Fleischer good
to see you both right let's just talk
about the origins of all this this is
important I think and the origins are
simple you have an email server
investigation that clearly they were
exonerating before investigating we have
there was written months before they
even interviewed the main principles
then we've got a dossier full of Russian
lies and propaganda that was used to
influence the American people that was
not true and then we know it was used as
a foundation to get a FISA warrant to
spy on a campaign and then a
president-elect to me that's the biggest
story in our lifetime oh it is such a
danger because FISA is all about spying
on Americans and you better have good
cause rather than op research that was
never verified as Glenn Simpson said and
you also have the office of the National
Security Advisor and others in the Obama
administration unmask reveal the names
of those Americans who were spied on and
then those names were put out for
political forum and the power did one a
day that's correct Sean and we wanted
Ashe administration virtually never did
it the amount of the times the Obama
administration did it compare to the
predecessor night
and dad 300 plus percent increase that
was one of the early stories we broke
yeah you know to me Shawn I think the
American people need to see it and I
think we need to put all the fixes in so
we protect everyone's constitutional
rights against unreasonable search and
seizure and we've got to vet out those
people that clearly purposely abuse this
program that was designed to keep
Americans safe yeah look I think that
there's a balance we've got to make sure
that people don't abuse the system that
we're not using government information
classified information to against
American citizens in a way that's being
alleged but we've also got to make sure
that it's done in a way that doesn't
reveal sources and methods so I think
there's a balance and I think that the
house should work with the Department of
Justice to make sure that this is done
in a responsible way so that we get the
objective of making sure that there's
transparency that people understand what
might have happened but we do so in a
way that doesn't burn a lot of the
sources and methods that are you okay if
that's important and we knew five at
least foreign intelligence agencies got
a hold of Clinton's email server
reclassified in special access
programming on there totally agree with
that
I mean I think that gets lost in the mix
here is it just because she didn't win
an election doesn't mean you get off of
being investigate you think the fix was
in when they exonerated her writing
exoneration letters before investigating
absolutely I mean they were talking
about how to water down the language in
the press release before the
investigation was concluded and you look
back at a lot of the things that are
being said now in terms of the text
messages and such and you've got to
wonder about what really win it there's
an IG report that's coming out in March
I think that that's going to be
revealing as far as what really happened
inside the department look one of the
things that's interesting about what the
Democrats are saying is that if you
questioned anybody in the government
right now your anti law enforcement
you're into this that's not true
99 percent of the people who work day in
and day and in law enforcement that is
more good hard-working people who care
about this country yeah you know one of
the other thing they watered down and I
only realized this last week one of the
emails at least will at least one more
than one of the emails Hillary sent went
to President Barack Obama from her
private server and
what the FBI did in the investigation
they changed the name that Hilary sent
it to Barak President Obama top official
senior government official they cleaned
it up to be back to Barack Obama let me
ask you this because they couldn't
handle the idea that the president knew
Hillary and committed crimes and they
covered for her that's not equal justice
under the law and the board never to it
they're using her pay for dossier to spy
on an opposition campaign that's how
severe is this tip so on you know that I
on your show have regularly defended Bob
Muller I used to defend James Comey on
his investigation of Hillary I can no
longer do that I think the investigation
into Hillary has turned out to be a sham
and anybody who loves the FBI as I've
been raised today will do in this
instance the FBI is let us all down that
is scary and and you're very you're not
me I'm a little bit more of a bomb
thrower all right when we come back